WILL BE CONDUCTING THE MEETING
THIS MORNING AND YOU ALL KNOW
I'M A VICE CHAIR OF SENATOR.
PAT BEATS SO I'D LIKE TO BRING
OUR ON MEETING TO ORDER AND ARE.
HAVE -- WE HAVE FORTY EIGHT
BILLS TO HEAR TODAY FIVE A WHICH
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A DO PASS
MOTION THE REMAINING OF BILLS OR
SUSPENSE ITEMS ALSO AB FIFTEEN
TEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES WAS
PULLED FROM THE FILE. TO BE
HEARD AT A LATER DATE.
AS A REMINDER LIKE TO REITERATE
OUR MESSAGE TO AUDIENCE MEMBERS
THAT TESTIMONY SHOULD BE LIMITED
TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL.
SO PLEASE REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY
POLICY DISCUSSIONS IN YOUR
COMMENTS IN TESTIMONY -- TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
PORTANTINO.
BATES HERE BATES HERE BRADFORD
DORADO. TO ROSS -- HERE HILL
HELLO HERE JONES JONES HERE WE
CASKEY.
BY CASKEY HERE.
IN A READY TO GO AND DO WE HAVE
ANY.
MEMBERS 2% YEAH IF NOT WE CAN
START DOWN THE SUSPENSE FILE.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE AB -- TWENTY THREE IF THE
CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE.
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
FINANCE GOOD MORNING MADAM VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JULIAN A DEER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL -- BUT WOULD KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ESTIMATES THIS BILL ROAD WILL
RESULT IN ONGOING COSTS
APPROXIMATELY. FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND A TO ACCOMPLISH THE
EXPANDED DUTIES OF THE OFFICE
REQUIRED BY THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THAT IS A CANDIDATE PER SUSPENSE
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION THE BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
NEXT ITEM AB SIXTY NINE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEEN.
CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE.
LOS HIGH HERE IN SUPPORT.
IN HERE TO OPPOSE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
THERE'S NO FILE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS ON THAT ONE NO.
THEY ON THE OUTS A CANDIDATE FOR
SUSPENSION WITHOUT OBJECTION IT
WILL -- GO TO CSUS FANS MANAGER
I'VE I FORGOT ON AB SIXTY NINE
THERE'S I HAVE AN EIGHTY YOU
BILL THERE'S HISTORY SURVEY THE
YOU BILLS ARE COMING IN.
THE AUTHORS HAVE AGREED TO A
RECONCILIATION OF THE CHAPTERS
SO THAT THE WE DON'T HAVE --
CONFLICT AMONGST THE BILL SO
THAT WOULDN'T WILL BE WORK UP
WITHIN COMMITTEE.
SO NOTED THANK YOU FROM.
SENATOR Y. KASKI [inaudible]
WE DO [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON.
HERE TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU HAVE TO
BILLS.
THE DEEP HOUSES AB SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR YOU PRESENTING ON BOTH OR
JUST CITY BASS JUST THE TO PASS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BEGIN.
THANK YOU A MATTER VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS BECAUSE AB SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR INCLUDES A COST
RECOVERY PROGRAM BUT THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS AGREED
THAT THE BILL PRESENTS.
A MINIMAL COST TO THE STATE.
SO THAT'S MY PRESENTATION.
IF SHORTER SWEET I'VE EVER.
ALL OF RESPECTFULLY AS SORT OF A
DO WE HAVE -- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
IS THAT.
HE'S GOT OKAY CANCERS GETTING
HIS ME.
WITH.
I YES WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ARE THERE ANY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DON'T
HAVE AN UP APPROVED POSITION ON
THIS BILL THAT WOULD KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IS A
COST RECOVERY ENTITY.
OTHER CHARGES FOR THE SERVICES
IT PROVIDES TO STATE AND LOCAL
ENTITIES WHICH GENERALLY DOESN'T
RESULT IN INCREASED COSTS TO THE
STATE -- WE WOULD NOTE HOWEVER
THAT THIS BILL MAY LIMIT THE
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO FULLY
RECOVER ITS COST FROM THE
CENTERS MOVE THE BILL.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED.
ANY COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
THEN.
METAL SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
BATES AYE BATES AYE BRADFORD
DORADO. TO RUSSELL AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WAKE HUSKY MAKOWSKI AYE.
THAT BILL BE PLACED ON CALL FOR
MEMBERS WHO NOT HERE YOU HAVE
VOTE FOR WILSON LAND ARE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARRIVED.
THANK YOU HOLIDAY CAMP AND I
DIDN'T LET YOU CLOSE BUT I'M
KIND OF GETTING USED TO MY
SCRIPT HERE SO.
IT'S ALL MAYBE YOU DIDN'T NEED
TO TALK PASSED THE DEAL SO IT'S
GOOD ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
STERN.
MR BLOOM ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM I
BELIEVE.
I CAN'T FOR VOTES. SIX MEMBERS.
THAT'S OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM YUP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I MEAN A
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT TWENTY NINE
CORRECT -- GOOD MORNING.
THE VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THIS BILL PERMITS THE CS USED TO
AWARD DOCTOR DEGREES IN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY TO COMPLY
WITH CHANGING PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS.
CURRENTLY SEVENTY SIX OF THE
NINETY SIX OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
PROGRAMS -- ARE MASTER DEGREE
PROGRAMS AROUND THE COUNTRY IN
THEIR TRANSITIONING TO DOCTOR
DEGREES INCLUDING ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S.
PRIVATE PROGRAM SO AB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE WILL PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS WITH AND AFFORDABLE
PUBLIC OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS
PURSUING.
A CAREER IN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY.
AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE WILL OCCUR
MINIMAL COSTS TO THE STATE AS
THE CSU WILL BE BEARING MUCH OF
THE COST OF TRANSITIONING THE
PROGRAMS. TO TESTIFY MAGGIE
WHITE IS HERE WITH THE CSU
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
HI GOOD MORNING MAGGIE WHITE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY I'LL BE VERY BRIEF I
THE START UP COSTS FOR THIS
PROGRAM WILL BE MINOR AND ABSORB
ALL THEY'LL BE ABSORBED BY THE
REGULAR CAMPUS PLANNING PROCESS
THAT OUR TWO CAMPUSES DOMINGUEZ
HILLS AND SAN JOSE STATE.
I ANY ON GOING COSTS SUCH AS
HIRING ADDITIONAL FACULTY I ANY
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL EQUIPMENT IN
RELATION TO THE DOCTOR PROGRAM
WITH SIMPLY BE ABSORBED THROUGH
I TUITION CHARGE FOR THE DOCTOR
LEVEL PROGRAM.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT THE MORNING
FIVE IN ALL TOMORROW ON BEHALF
OF THE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANY HERE IN OPPOSITION SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
NONE THEM OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THANK YOU WE DON'T HAVE APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS BILL.
AS THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE JUST
NOTED THE IMMEDIATE COST
IMPLEMENT THIS BILL ARE
ESTIMATED TO BE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE -- AND IMPLEMENTATION
MAY BE ACHIEVED BY CONVERTING
THE TWO EXISTING MASTER'S DEGREE
PROGRAMS TO THE DOCTORAL
PROGRAMS.
A WE WOULD NOTE HOWEVER THAT
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLANTATION IN THE FUTURE OF
COULD DIVERT A COMMENSURATE
LEVEL OF ONGOING RESOURCES FROM
OTHER PURPOSES WHICH COULD
RESULT IN PROGRAMMATIC
PRODUCTIONS TO OTHER ACTIVITIES
OR CREATE SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION -- SENATOR.
JONES THANK YOU THE MANAGER FOR
THE AUTHOR OR OR MS WHITE --
EITHER.
HAZARD I I JUST LEARNED TODAY I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THIS YEAR'S YOU
HAD TO COME TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO GET PERMISSION.
TO HAVE A DOCTORATE PROGRAM HAS
THERE BEEN ANY CONVERSATION AND
I KNOW IT'S PART OF THE ORIGINAL.
CHARTER OF THE SYSTEM -- AND THE
UC IN VERSES THE UC SYSTEM.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY CONVERSATION
OF REMOVING THAT -- REQUIREMENT
AND JUST GIVEN THE CSU A TIME I
MEAN IN DEVELOPING ITS OWN
DOCTOR PROGRAMS.
NOT A DISCUSSION THAT I'M AWARE
OF BUT THAT WOULD MEAN IT HASN'T
HAPPENED PERHAPS.
AS WHITE.
I WOULD AGREE WITH THAT I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANY DISCUSSION AT THAT
LEVEL I WOULD SAY THAT THE
DOCTOR PROGRAMS THAT WE DO
CURRENTLY OFFER WE DO HAVE FOR
AND HELP TO ADD THIS IS A DEATH.
ARE THINGS THAT OUR PARTNERS
OVER THE UC I DO NOT OFFER
THINGS THAT WE UNIQUELY CAN
OFFER TO OUR STUDENTS WE ALSO
OFFER SOME DOCTORS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE UC AS WELL --
BUT NOT AWARE OF ANY ANY
CONVERSATIONS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
LEVEL OKAY WAS A CSU GRAD I'M
GONNA.
LOOK MORE I JUST LEARNED THIS
TODAY SO A LOOK MORE INTO IT BUT
I AM SUPPORTIVE OF THE OF THIS
BILL OBVIOUSLY.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
DORADO.
DORADO AYE HILL.
HILL I JONES.
JONES I'VE Y. CASKEY.
MY COUNTY I IT HAS FIVE VOTES
SCHOOL FOR THE ROLE OF AN FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
STRICTLY [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible] ELEVEN SIXTY
SIXTY FOUR THERE.
IS ALSO PRESENT.
PRESENTING MR.
OKAY SIR OKAY [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR YOU'RE
PRESENTING ON YOUR OWN BILL I
UNDERSTAND AND THEN FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND NAZARIAN I'M ABLE TO
DO THAT IS SO PLEASE THE CHAIR
YES YES -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
GOOD MORNING -- SENATORS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AT ELEVEN SIXTY
FOUR THIS A BILL THAT I'VE
AUTHORED THAT AUTHORIZES THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO START THE
SALE PROCESS FOR THE DOWNTOWN.
SAN DIEGO STATE BUILDING --
CURRENTLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY OCCUPIES TWO
FULL CITY BLOCKS IN DOWNTOWN SAN
DIEGO -- THESE DO NOT BE SPEAK
WELL OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE FREQUENT IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD NUISANCE A
COMPLAINT OF THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY FOUR POINT IT'S AN
INCREASE CREDIBLY INEFFICIENT
USE OF LAND.
MANY OF THE OCCUPANTS OF THE
BILLION AREN'T HAPPY BEING
THEY'RE SEEKING TO ESCAPE THE
BUILDING AS BEST THIS IS PRESENT
ON SITE -- AND IMPORTANTLY I
THINK IT'S WRONG EXAMPLE FOR
STATUS AT THE MANY MORE
COMMITTEE STEP UP FOR HOUSING --
BOTH OF THESE PROPERTIES COULD
BE SIGNIFICANT LOCATE OVER THIS
PROPERTY THESE TWO CITY BLOCKS
COULD BE SNIPPET LOCATION FOR
ADDITIONAL HOUSING.
A WITH YOUR VOTE TODAY WE CAN
KEEP THIS BILL MOVING FOR YOU
KNOW FOR CREATE A SITUATION
WHERE THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO --
OR LOCAL HOUSING FOR A PROVIDER
CAN CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MORE CALIFORNIANS WERE CITY
AGAINST TO LIVE IN THEIR CITY A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
THERE'S NONE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DON'T
HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION -- BUT
WOULD KNOW THAT TO THE EXTENT
THE PROPERTY IS IDENTIFIED AS
SURPLUS AND SUBSEQUENTLY SOLD
THE STATE WILL RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL REVENUE.
I WOULD ADDITIONALLY NOTE THAT
ANY ESTIMATE OF PROCEEDS IS
PREMATURE PENDING AN APPRAISAL
OF WHICH WILL BE COMPLETED ON
THE PROPERTY IS OFFERED FOR SALE.
THE GROSS PROCEEDS OF THE
PROPERTY SALE WILL BE USED TO
REIMBURSE TGS FOR ANY COSTS OR
EXPENSES INCURRED IN THE
DISPOSITION OF THE PROPERTY.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S A MOTION AND THEN --
SENATOR JONES ADJUSTER A QUICK
QUESTION -- WHAT HAS THERE BEEN
DISCUSSION REGARDING THE OFFICES
THAT ARE LOCATED IN THE BUILDING
NOW WORK?
I THINK YOU'RE DISTRICT OFFICERS
COUPLE OTHERS -- WHERE WOULD
THEY MOVED -- TO I THINK THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO BE EXPLORED --
I THINK THERE ARE THERE ARE
OTHER STATE BUILDINGS -- IN THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO -- THERE'S
ALSO THE LIKELIHOOD AS MANY
OTHER STATES HAVE DONE WHICH IS
TO MOVE INTO LEAST SPACE -- THAT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE LONG TERM
CAPITAL EXPENSES THAT A BUILDING
OF THIS AGE.
THE STATE IS NOT MAINTAIN THIS
BUILDING SENATOR -- AND IT SHOWS --
IT IS I THINK CURRENT A
SUBSTANTIAL COST TO TAXPAYERS SO
I RECOGNIZE THAT THE TRADE OFF
BETWEEN AN OWNED AND LEASED
FACILITY -- BUT I WOULD
REPRESENTS YOU RIGHT NOW THIS IS
NOT STATE IN THE STATE ANY MONEY
ON TO THE EXTENT OF THE CITY SAN
DIEGO AS AN EQUAL VINTAGE
BUILDING ACROSS THE STREET --
CITY EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE CITY
TO IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
BECAUSE OF THE XPRESSPOST
RESPOSTAS -- I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR HELP AND SUPPORT DISPOSING
OF THIS LIABILITY TO TAXPAYERS
AND AS DEPARTMENT FINANCE
MENTIONS POTENTIALLY REALIZE A
REVENUE SOURCE THE PERHAPS WE
CAN INVEST BACK INTO THESE
COMMUNITIES.
I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS AND YOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL
THE AND AGREE THAT THE BILL THE
BUILDING.
PROBABLY HAS A HIGHER INVEST USE
HAS SOMETHING ELSE SO I SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU SIR.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION CRAFT YES
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SH BUT
THEY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
CALDERON MADAM SECRETARY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
BATES AYE BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE DORADO.
TERRAZZO AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES I WOULD
CASKEY.
MICHALSKI I THAT BILL HAS SIX
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF AN
ABSENT MEMBERS ARE HERE.
BIG CENTER.
I'M IF I MAIL PROCEED -- WITH
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
OH FIVE THIS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THIS AREA -- AB
THREE OH FIVE A PROVIDES THE LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND
POWER AND OTHER SIMILARLY
SITUATED PUBLIC WATER UTILITIES
THE CONTINUED USE OF AN
IMPORTANT FINANCING TOOL ENACTED
TWENTY FOURTEEN THROUGH ASSEMBLY
BILL.
EIGHT FIFTY WHICH FUNDS
GROUNDWATER CLEANUP PROJECTS --
MISTER IS THERE HAS A NUMBER OF
OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT POINTS
BUT INTEREST TIME I'LL SKIP
THOSE AND JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I'VE OF WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION SPEAKERS NINE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
ANTICIPATE THE IMPACT TO BE
MINOR OBSERVABLE.
WE HAVE A MOTION ANY COMMENTS
FROM -- COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
ABOUT FIVE IS THERE EXPECT
FASTER I BOOK [inaudible]
QUESTIONS YEAH.
THE UNKNOWN MAN SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO.
HELL I JONES JONES I WIECKOWSKI
I CASKEY I AND HEALTH SIX MODES.
SIX VOTES WILL HOLD IT OPEN BIG
AND CHECK FOR THE ARGUE OFFERS.
THEY WILL GO BACK TO THE
SUSPENSE.
BOB AB FOURTEEN NINETY THREE
FROM A TING.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OVER
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM A COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT IS A CANDIDATE FOR
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION IT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
BY AB ONE FORTY THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
KENNEDY FOR SUSPENSE.
IN HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
BERMAN FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE ONE
POSITION -- AND COSTS OF ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
UNTIL THE BILL SUNSETS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS.
THAT IS A CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION THE BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
ITEM AB FOURTEEN TEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TAKE A MORNING MY NAME IS
PATRICK MORE TEAR THEM WITH
MISSION READINESS AND READY
NATION AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IN OPPOSITION ANYONE HERE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AT THIS BILL CREATES A
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURE IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY A BY
ESTABLISHING THE INITIATIVE
SUBJECT AN UNSPECIFIED
APPROPRIATION NOT INCLUDED IN
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ESTIMATES THIS BILL
WOULD COST FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND AND UP TO THREE
POSITIONS TO ADMINISTER THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE ON THAT
BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB ONE
SIXTY FOUR CERVANTES.
ARM.
CANDY FOR SUSPENSE [inaudible]
TWO HUNDRED WITNESSES IAN
SUPPORT.
MANY HERE IN. TO OPPOSE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WHEN OF JUSTICE JUSTICE
ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND COST OF
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN 201-924-0080
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN?
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AN ON
GOING FOR THE WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEASURE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL COULD
POTENTIALLY INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF COMMITMENTS TO STATE PRISON
AND OR RESULT IN LINK YOUR
PRISON SENTENCES UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
THE MAGNITUDE OF WHICH IS ON NOW.
QUESTIONS YES.
WE KNOW WHAT ASKING.
IT'S AN ALL THAT INFORMATION A
RESTRAINING ORDERS ALREADY
ONLINE THAT THAT THE CALIFORNIA.
THE LEASE.
COOPER HAVE AN BUT THEY ALREADY
HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
AT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THEY DO
HAVE THAT INFORMATION AT LEAST
SPECIFICALLY TO THOSE WITH THE
ORDERS THAT ARE OUT OF
JURISDICTION THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE APP'S PROGRAM.
I'M NOT CLEAR IF THEY HAVE.
pWOULDN'T THAT COSTS GO TO THE
LOCAL AGENCY OR THE PERSON WHO
IS. ONE TO FIVE BY THE GUN RIGHT
FOR SAID DOJ.
I THINK SOME OF THE COSTS THAT
DOJ IS ASSOCIATING WITH IS AN
INCREASE IN WORKLOAD FOR THE
ARREST PRINTS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE ASSISTED WITH HIS ADDITIONAL
AMOUNT OF THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB ARE -- THREE OH THREE FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES HI.
THOSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANY HERE IN OPPOSITION.
BERMAN FINANCE NO FILE.
I AM COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NONE WITHOUT OBJECTION THEM THAT
BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
NEXT ARE WE HAVE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AB.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE THOSE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
IN HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THAT IS A CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE --
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
ESTIMATES THIS BILL WILL RESULT
IN MINOR OBSERVABLE COSTS.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ESTIMATES THE NEED FOR HALF A
POSITION AND NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR SUBSEQUENT
YEARS -- IN INCREASE GENERAL
FUND COSTS RELATED TO THE BILL.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL
WILL GO TO CSUS FANS.
ARE WE DID AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
THAT WAS DUE PASS ARE MOVING ON
AB ONE EIGHTY NINE FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF KAMARG THEY'RE DONE.
THOSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN.
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OF WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE -- AND WE KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ANTICIPATES MINOR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON AB ONE NINETY SEVEN
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
THOSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
LIZABETH ASK OF ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE HAVE A
SUPPORTER FROM AND A POSITION IN
THE I'M I'M IS REALLY JUST
POLICY FOCUSED THANK YOU.
ANY HERE IT CAN OPPOSITION. NINE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THIS BILL COULD CREATE A
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
I WITH KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS
PROVIDE AT LEAST ONE FULL DAY
PROGRAM BY THE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SCHOOL YEAR.
WE CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE
INFORMATION ON THE NUMBER
SCHOOLS EXCLUSIVELY OFFERING
PART DAY KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS.
SO IT IS DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
AN ACCURATE COST ESTIMATE.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THIS BILL
DOESN'T ALIGN WITH THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT WHICH
PROVIDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR KINDERGARTEN
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION. TO
INCENTIVIZE RATHER THAN MANDATE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO CONVERT
THEIR PARTY PROGRAMS TO FULL DAY.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE [inaudible]
AB [inaudible]
OUR TWO OR THREE FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
APARTMENT A FINANCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES THIS BILL
RESULT IN COST TOTALING FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLAR SPECIAL FUND INITIALLY
AND UP TO TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS SPECIAL
FUND ON GOING.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IN WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
HE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA HOUSE
WITH A PRECIPITATION OKAY.
AB ARE TWO THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- GARCIA.
HERE IN SUPPORT WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU KELLY JANA I'M A
PARENT OF A TWENTY THREE YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER WITH EPILEPSY AND
SEVERAL POLICY.
AND HAVE NAVIGATED THE
COMPLICATED SPECIAL EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND I THINK THIS BILL
THIS RESOURCE WOULD PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED INFORMATION FOR PARENTS
AND STUDENTS SO THAT OUR STUDENT
OUTCOMES WOULD BE.
BETTER FOR THE CHILDREN IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OUR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YES WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AS IT
CREATES ONGOING COST PRESSURE OF
UP TO SIX POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND. TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CENTERS FROM.
FOURTEEN TO THIRTY TWO
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ESTIMATES ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND -- COST
PRESSURES TO HIRE STAFF FOR THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ROOMS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
NOT.
THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB TWO FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
DARLING.
IN SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I SAW THAT I SAW
SOMEBODY STEPPING UP.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS POLLY --
BEHALF OF SHASTA AND SISKIYOU
COUNTY IS IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THEY REALLY REALLY NEED
THIS RELIEF THANK YOU.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS SENATOR DOLLIES.
ASSEMBLY BILL BEFORE HE BECAME A
SENATOR SO I DIDN'T MENTION THAT
SO.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
ESTIMATES THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
WAVING THE LOCAL MATCH FOR THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FIRES.
IS APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND.
AND ALL THE RECOGNIZING THIS
HAD ON THESE COMMUNITIES --
WHERE OPOSED TO THIS BILL AS A
STATE IS TAKEN OTHER MEASURES TO
BOLSTER LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES AND SUPPORT THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY SAID THE
AFFECTED?
COUNTIES INCLUDING PROVIDING A
HUNDRED FORTY ONE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN SUPPORT FROM
THE DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT. FOR DEBRIS
REMOVAL COSTS AND SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
PROPERTY TAX LOSS BACK FILLED TO
THE EFFECTIVE COUNTIES.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE YOU KNOW --
THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE COOPER.
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES ESTIMATES ANNUAL COST
OF SIX HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES ONE TIME COSTS OF
ROUGHLY THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
ASSIST WITH THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE SYSTEM AND SERVERS TO HOUSE
THE DATA.
WITNESSES IN NO.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
I WAS THE TO YOU.
BEEN WITHOUT A CHECK.
YEAH WHO WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINETY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT JOHN LEVEL FROM THE LA
COUNTY PROFESSIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
AND I MUST SAY WE ARE MYSTIFIED
THAT THIS BILL IS -- ON THE
SUSPENSE FILE AT ALL -- THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ANALYZE THIS BILL AND
KIMBERLY HORIUCHI WHO'S.
VERY RESPECTED OVER THERE AND
ALSO HAS DEEP PUBLIC SAFETY
EXPERTISE -- ON FISCAL AFFECTS
SAID THREE THINGS MINOR AND
ABSORB ACOSTA CDC ARE.
MINOR COST TO CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES POSSIBLE ONE TIME AND
YOU'LL NON REIMBURSABLE COST IN
THE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
THERE IS.
LIKE FIFTEEN TIMES OWNS
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT YOUR
COMMITTEE HAS SAID ABOUT THIS
AND WE ARE SHOCKED BEEN
ASTONISHED -- AT THIS FINDING.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL SHOULD
BE VOTED ON ON ITS MERITS WE
BELIEVE THAT THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GOT IT SPOT ON RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY OR
IN ANY OTHER SINCE SUPPORT I
WILL HAVE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
RESPOND.
BY ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DON'T
HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION ON
THIS BILL BUT WOULD NOTE THAT --
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT STATE REIMBURSABLE
COSTS AND WHILE THE MAGNITUDE OF
THESE COST IS UNKNOWN -- WE WE
ESTIMATE IT COULD BE IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS -- WE WOULD
NOTE THAT AT THE TIME OF OUR
ANALYSIS THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
DIDN'T HAVE AN UPDATED FISCAL
BASED ON THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU DID YOU HAVE ANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH -- THE
APARTMENT FINANCE SOLVE THE
ASSEMBLY OF REVIEW OF THIS JUST
TO ANSWER ON THE WE HAVE NOT BUT
I CAN.
REACH OUT TOWARDS THAT WOULD BE
IN.
TERMS OF RESOLUTION OF THE ISSUE
BROUGHT TO US BY.
THE PUBLIC SPEAKER.
ANY COMMENTS ON QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
HEARING NONE OF THAT WILL AGO
JUST TO SUSPEND SOME WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
A. B. R. C. WITH THE THREE OH
FIVE AB.
THREE NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN THIS AREA.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
NONE.
CORPORATE FINANCE THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATES
COST TO THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL TO RANGE
FROM A ONE TIME COST OF SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
UP TO TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS ONE MILLION OF WHICH
WOULD BE ONE TIME IN NATURE
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO QUESTIONS THEM THERE IS A
CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE AND IT
WILL GO TO SPELLS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB.
FOUR TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAZARIAN.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
A YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE A BASED ON THE FAMOUS
PUBLICATION THAT IS CONSIDERED
TO BE THE EXISTING NATIONAL
STANDARD FOR INVENTORYING BUILT
BUILDINGS.
THE SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION
ESTIMATES THE COMPLETION OF AN
INVENTORY -- WOULD COST FORTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
COMMISSION ALSO ESTIMATES THAT
THE INITIAL ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL TWO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
UNTIL THE INVENTORY SURVEYS
ASSESSMENTS AND EVALUATIONS ARE
COMPLETE.
MANY MEMBERS COMMENTS QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
NONE.
OUR THAT BILL WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS ARIA.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
APARTMENT FINANCE.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
ESTIMATES ONGOING ANNUAL GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE LOW MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL DOESN'T
SPECIFY A FUNDING SOURCE FOR
THESE COSTS -- FINALLY IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FINDS A STATE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE TERMS
OF THE HIGH CAP GRANT THE STATE
COULD LOSE FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS COMMENTS. NINE
WITHOUT OBJECTION THEM THAT BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO COMMENTS
THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPEND.
AB ARE THREE THREE NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR WHEN.
BECAUSE IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THIS BILL RESULT IN
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT STATE REMEMBER
PERSONAL COSTS TO LOCAL POLICE
AND SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS.
OF THE MAGNITUDE OF THE COST OF
SUCH MANDATE IS UNKNOWN BUT
LIKELY IN THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL ESTIMATES COST
BETWEEN TWO MILLION AND TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
TRAIN OFFICERS AND SERGEANTS ON
THE NEW POLICIES.
ADDITIONALLY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY POLICE
DEPARTMENTS WOULD ALSO HAVE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
MEASURE.
WITH THE MEMBERS.
NONE OF US THE SIX SENATOR
MCCARTHY.
IS THE PROBLEM THAT THE CHP AND
LOCAL AGENCIES DON'T HAVE
WRITTEN POLICIES AND STANDARDS
AND THEY HAVE.
TO THEIR SWITCHES TO AN AN ON
THE FLY.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE COST IS
GONNA COME IN BY REQUIRING IT
AND STATUTES THE PROPS
ADDITIONAL COSTS YES AS WELL AS
A MANDATE TO THE LOCAL AGENCIES.
TO THE JUST THE ENFORCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS JUST SORT OF
ON THAT HOW THEY FEEL I DID I
MEAN THEY LOOK AT THE ORDER AND
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY.
SPECIFIC TRAINING ON HOW THAT
WOULD BE -- BEST.
AND IMPLEMENTED THIS BILL
PRESCRIBE SPECIFIC WRITTEN
POLICIES AND STANDARDS SO THAT
AGAIN WOULD PROMPT ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS OKAY PROCESS
THINKING COSTS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS NONE THEM
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE AB. THREE FORTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
BERMAN FINANCE ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT THIS BILL WILL
COST APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN THE FIRST YEAR.
AND FIVE HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING AVAILABLE
FOR GRANT AWARDS REMAINS AND
SPECIFIED IN THE BILL AT THIS
TIME -- BUT ASSUMING A MAXIMUM
NUMBER OF FIFTY GRANTS AT THE
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR LEVEL THE
TOTAL AT LOCAL ASSISTANCE COSTS
WOULD BE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND JULIE
[inaudible]
FIRST.
NO COMMENTS THEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT WILL GO TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY BILL. THREE
FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
THIS BILL WILL LEAD TO
EXPENDITURES OF AT LEAST THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
OVER TWO YEARS THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL AND THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION ESTIMATE
THEIR COSTS RELATED TO THIS BILL
WOULD BE MINOR ANSWERABLE.
MANY MEMBERS NO COMMENTS DOWN ON
THIS BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SIX SEVENTY
SEVEN AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOICE A BILL.
THOSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AT A COST OF FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN THE
FIRST YEAR.
AND FIVE HUNDRED SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER WOULD BE NECESSARY.
FOR THIS BILL.
MANY MEMBERS NO COMMENT.
THEREFORE WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS
BILL ILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB
THREE SEVENTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF OF A PALE -- HERE IN
SUPPORT ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DON'T
HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION ON
THIS BILL THAT WOULD KNOW THAT
IT WOULD EXPOSE THE STATE TO
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS AND LIABILITY
ISSUES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS
WOULD LIKELY NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO DRAFT THE
REGULATIONS AND PROVIDE GUIDANCE
TO THE DEPARTMENTS ON
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM.
TWENTY MEMBERS.
NO COMMENTS THEREFORE WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS BILL GOES TO
SUSPENSE AB.
FOUR OH SIX FAMILY MEMBER -- Là
MON.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES
COSTS OF ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE DISABILITY
INSURANCE FUND WHICH INCLUDES
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEM UPDATES.
AND FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO DEVELOP BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS IN STAFF TRAINING.
ADDITIONALLY -- THERE MAY BE
SIGNIFICANT UNKNOWN COSTS
INCURRED -- TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
NON ENGLISH NON ENGLISH LANGUAGE
FORMS OF FOR LANGUAGES THAT GREW
TO REPRESENT AT LEAST 5% OF
EDIE'S SERVICE SPACE.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO
COMMENTS THEREFORE WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE BILL WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
AB FOR FIFTEEN ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
THOSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO THE
EXTENT EDITION ALL CLAIMS ARE
SUBMITTED FOR REIMBURSEMENT THIS
BILL WOULD HAVE AN UNKNOWN
IMPACT ON THE RESTITUTION FUND.
THE AMOUNT OF WHICH IS A UNKNOWN
BUT POTENTIALLY IN THE LOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
MANY MEMBERS NO COMMENTS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THEM THAT BILL
WILL GO TO SPAM AB FOR SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
HERE IN SUPPORT ANYONE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AGRICULTURE ESTIMATES THE BILL
REQUIRE ONE POSITION AND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO PERFORM THE
FUNCTIONS IN THIS BILL -- WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED RECENTLY ESTABLISHED A
FARM EQUITY ADVISOR WITHIN THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF THAT MAY
SUPPORT SOME OF THE EFFORTS
IDENTIFIED IN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE OUT OBJECTION NOW ON THAT
BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB FOUR
FOUR SEVEN FOUR FORTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON.
CLOSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE HERE IN A IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THIS BILL RESULT
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS OF FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO COMMENTS.
THEY ARE NOW WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT BILL GO TO SUSPENSE EIGHTY
FOR SIXTY NINE PETRIE-NORRIS.
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
NONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE ESTIMATES
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND.
AND ONE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING TO
SUPPORT AB ONE POSITION TO FILL
THIS BILLS REQUIREMENTS.
WE KNOW THAT THE COST TO EACH
STATE AGENCY TO COMPLY WITH THIS
MEASURE COULD BE MATERIAL WHICH
MAY OR MAY NOT BE OBSERVABLE.
THANK YOU.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO COMMENTS
THEREFORE WITHOUT OBJECTION ON
THIS BILL WILL GO TO SPENCE AB
FOR SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO.
HERE IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION. NINE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS INDICATES THIS
BILL WOULD RESULT IN COST OF AT
LEAST TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FOR STAFFING AND ASSOCIATED
COSTS.
MANY MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
NINE ON THERE FOR WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT BILL WILL GO JUST
SUSPENSE AB TEN NINETY THREE OF
THESE ARE OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO SOME BILLS -- ANY
OF SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YES WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AS IT IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE EFFORTS
ALREADY BEING IMPLEMENTED BY THE
WATER BOARD IN RESPONSE TO A
RECENT AUDIT BY THE STATE ORDER.
AUDITOR.
AND THE WATER BOARD ESTIMATES
COST TO THIS BILL APPROXIMATELY
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE WASTE DISCHARGE
PERMIT FUND.
ADDITIONALLY WOULD KNOW THE TO
THE TIMELINE IN THIS BILL IS
UNWORKABLE.
MANY MEMBERS COMMENTS THERE ARE
NONE THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS
BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE A. B.
R. [inaudible]
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUBIO [inaudible]
ANY SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
ESTIMATES THIS BILL WOULD COST
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY [inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO COMMENTS THEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS BILL WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
WE ARE OUT TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO'S BILL HE DOES HAVE ONE
NOW I DO PARA CB.
FOUR NINETY SEVEN I DO NOT SEE
HIM HERE SHOULD BE TAKEN OUT THE
SUSPENSE.
ON HOLD OFF ON BOTH OF THEM OKAY
WE TAKE THE SUSPECT.
OKAY THEN IT WILL TAKE THE
SUSPENSE -- ITEM AB.
EIGHT NINETY FOUR ARE THOSE HERE
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THIS BILL
COULD RESULT IN COST OF
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND
ONLY.
A FOR THE NEW POSITIONS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
ADDITIONALLY TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE EMPLOYEES SALARIES EXCEED
CONVERTED CIVIL SERVICE SALARIES
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN
INCREASED FUTURE PENSION
LIABILITIES.
WITH THE MEMBERS NO COMMENTS.
THERE FOR OUR WITHOUT OBJECTION
ON THIS BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB FIVE TWENTY FOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW.
HERE IN SUPPORT ANY SPEAKERS
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
BERMAN FINANCE YES WE'RE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE
RESULTS AND POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT STATE REIMBURSABLE
COST TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO COMMENTS
THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION ARE THIS
BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB SIX SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- FRIEDMAN.
IN SUPPORT SPEAKERS NINE IN
OPPOSITION. NINE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO FILE.
THE FILE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ANY COMMENTS.
ARE THERE FOR WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIS BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB SEVEN TWENTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI BOB HERE IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS HERE SUPPORT WE HAVE.
MALONEY I'M SUPERINTENDENT
PRESIDENT OF EL CAMINO COLLEGE
AND WE ARE JUST SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING VICE CHAIR -- MORE
TAURUS I AM THE ASSOCIATE VICE
PRESIDENT ECONOMIC AFFAIRS A
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TWENTY ON
BEHALF OF THE EIGHT THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED PLUS.
OFFICERS THAT WE TREAT EACH YEAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. NINE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DON'T
HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION ON
THIS BILL WHAT WOULD NOTE THAT --
WE ESTIMATE THE COSTS -- TO
CREATE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND -- IN THE TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS.
BEFORE WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ONTO ASSEMBLYMEMBER CROOKS BILLS.
AB.
SEVEN THIRTY THREE WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SHOULD
THERE BE AN APPROPRIATION FOR
THIS PURPOSE THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ESTIMATES THIS BILL REQUIRES
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT.
AND THREE POSITIONS OVER THREE
YEARS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS COMMENTS. NINE
MEN WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS BILL
WILL GO O SUSPENSE AB NINE
FORTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
ALTHOUGH THE BILL'S PROVISIONS
PERTAINING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
WORKLOAD ARE CONTINGENT ON
AVAILABLE FUNDING.
WE BELIEVE THE PROVISIONS
PERTAINING TO LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS IN JURISDICTIONS WOULD
IN PRACTICE A RESULT IN THE NEED
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO CREATE
METHODS AND STANDARDS.
THE DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES COSTS
OF UP TO SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ACCOUNT -- AND THREE
POSITIONS ANNUALLY FOR FOUR
YEARS.
I THINK WE'RE ON THE WRONG BILL
WE'RE ON AB NINE FORTY FOUR THAT
HAS TO DO WITH CAL WORKS AND I
THINK DID WE JUMPED SEVEN THIRTY
THREE ON THE HAZARDOUS WASTE.
I WENT TO THE NEXT BILL --
THAT'S OKAY I'M TRYING. FOUR
NINE FORTY FOUR I HAVE NO FILE.
NO FILE ON A. B. SEVEN THIRTY
THREE NO ON AB NINE FORTY FOUR
EIGHTY NINE FORTY FOUR NO FILE.
ANY QUESTIONS.
NINE DâN NOW WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
AB FIFTEEN NINETY SIX AND OF
THEIR FREE OF OF THE COMEDIAN
COMMITTEE GO YEAH THIS IS THE
COMMITTEE BILL.
REQUIREMENTS.
DEAL.
YES BERMAN FIFTY TOXIC
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
[inaudible]
ARIEL'S.
ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YES THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ESTIMATES
COST UP TO SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ACCOUNT. FOR THIS BILL.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS HEARING NONE THEN
WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS BILL WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JOINS JONES SAWYER AB.
NINE TWENTY SEVEN ARE OUT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
FILE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
HEARING NO COMMENTS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS BILL WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH AB.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
IN OPPOSITION.
THERE ARE NONE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NO COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THEM THIS BILL WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
AB ELEVEN FIFTY THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THIS BILL WILL LIKELY RESULT IN
A REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE
WITH ANNUAL COSTS UP TO
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND.
BY REQUIRING DISTRICTS TO
PROVIDE THE ANNUAL EMPLOYEE
TRAINING IN THIS BILL.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS.
HEARING NONE ARE WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS BILL WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
AND THE LAST BILL ON THE
SUSPENSE FILE AB ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE OF OUR CARE ON ARE ANY
MEMBER ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF AT LEAST NINE HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO
COMPLY WITH THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL.
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COSTS OF
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
201-920-34000 DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER -- FINALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
ANTICIPATES REVENUES OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN 201-921-0040 SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND FORTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO THE FINGERPRINT
VIA COUNT.
ANY ARE QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. NINE DOWN WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT BILL WILL GOTO
SUSPENSE WE HAVE WHEN BILL LEFT
WHICH IS A DO PASS.
AND HE'S JUST IN TIME TO HEAR
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY SEVEN IF WE
HAVE AN OFFICE.
HE WAS APPARENTLY HOMES.
THANK YOU WILL BE TAKING OVER.
I DIDN'T MOVE [inaudible]
COST.
MISTER CHAIR WELCOME.
I'M I'M HERE SPECIALLY APPEARING
FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
AB.
FOUR NINE SEVEN IN THE BILL
SIMPLY -- EXTENDS TO DATE AND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO COLLECT
THE SURCHARGE ON INTEREST --
TELEPHONE SERVICES TO FUND THE
DEAF IN -- DISABLED -- TELL
COMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM AND IT'S
MINOR INEXORABLE COST.
ARE WE HAVE A MOTION OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE WEBMASTER WE HAVE -- ONE AIR
CARRIERS WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT AND THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE AND
IT HELPS A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH --
HEARING IMPAIRMENTS AND WE THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WHERE IT'S
POOR WE URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
THEIR FILE.
YES -- THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION DOESN'T EXPECT THE
FISCAL IMPACT.
FROM THIS BILL.
GREAT WE HAVE A MOTION TO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST NOTED
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FOR THE
DEAF IS IN MY DISTRICT AND THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL.
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT THEY SERVE --
CAN I PUT THANK YOU IS WHAT
COUNTY.
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD TO RAZA
DORADO AYE HILL JONES.
JONES I WIECKOWSKI MAKOVSKY I
ZERO THAT BILL IS DO WE HAVE --
ARE THE TWO MEMBERS.
PLEASE DON'T HAVE. TO HAVE HIM
COME BACK TO THE BILL'S ON CALL.
SO EVERYTHING IS ON CALL AT THIS
POINT RIGHT.
WILL JUST GIVE UP WOMEN THEY
CAN'T
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
OUR BY LIFTING A CALL ON SEVEN
FIVE FOUR GRAYSON.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BRADFORD.
OKAY.
WE'LL HOLD IT WILL HOLD FOR A
COUPLE MORE MINUTES SO KEEP THAT
ON CALL.
OKAY THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
AB THREE OH FIVE IN THIS AREA IN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO I
PORTANTINO I OKAY SO THAT IS OUT.
THAT IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
FOUR NINETY SEVEN CENT THIAGO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR BRADFORD.
HELL.
I THAT'S ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
CENTER AB THANK YOU JERRY AB.
EIGHT TWENTY NINE BLOOM
[inaudible]
THE MOTION.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FOR PORTANTINO I AM
PORTANTINO AYE BRADFORD.
IT WILL HOLD ON OUT FOR MISTER
BRADFORD.
THEN WE HAVE -- AND IT AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FOUR GLORIA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO HI. FOR THE SEVENTH
SO THAT'S OUT SEVEN ZERO SO WE
HAVE. ONE TWO THREE BILLS ON
CALL ALL RIGHT FOR MISTER
BRADFORD WILL GIVE HIM A COUPLE
MORE MINUTES [inaudible]
CASH.
OKAY THANK YOU
THE CALL ON A V.
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR GRAYSON.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BRADFORD.
HI BRADFORD AYE THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN ZERO OKAY THEN WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO A BEFORE NINETY SEVEN
CENTS THIAGO PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
AND OF SEVEN TO ZERO ALL RIGHT
THAT'S OUT SEVEN ZERO THAN OUR
LAST BILL MISTER BLOOM.
AB.
EIGHT TWENTY NINE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
THAT PHYLLIS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS TO DISPENSE WITH.
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED